[Musique]
lorsque j'ai su que j'étais à accepter
pour la conférence la première question
qui m'est venu à l'esprit c'était
pourquoi pourquoi moi et pas quelqu'un
parmi vous ici aujourd'hui peut-on après
j'ai commencé à me poser une autre
question
en effet je me suis dit de quoi de quoi
vais-je par les caisses qui moi
m'intéresse tellement qu'est ce que j'ai
appris et que j'aimerai bien partagé
avec jacques un chacun d'entre vous ici
présents aujourd'hui bien en essayant de
répondre à cette question
j'ai tout simplement été confronté par
une peinture une partie une voiture en
particulier par un artiste italien qui
se trouvent ici derrière moi en effet
pour la plupart ses pâtures peut
paraître anodine voire même complexe
n'est ce pas pensez-y un homme qui est
comme effacé un homme qu'on voit à peine
je suis sûr que là parmi vous la plupart
vous demande pourquoi je vous montre ça
est bien réfléchie c'est à cette
question qui dans cette salle
aujourd'hui
n'ayez pas peur allez-y qui peut
prétendre haut et fort qu'il n'a jamais
à un moment donné dans sa vie en
particulier était confronté par ce
sentiment de sentiment d'être comme
effacé ce sentiment d'être comme
disloqué de qui il est vraiment allez-y
lever la main
comme je peux le constater et comme vous
pouvez le constater également la plupart
d'entre nous à un moment donné de notre
vie nous avons été tous confrontés à ce
sentiment et la plupart d'entre nous
vivons avec ce sentiment d'être
différent et bien cette différence en
effet mois durant toute mon existence en
nature dit oh oui m'a dit li les
différents hommes et laisse tomber
n'essayez pas de le comprendre lui il
est différent
toute ma vie on m'a qualifié de
différent et c'est marrant car lorsque
je demande aux autres de me définir
il ya souvent deux descriptions que j'ai
en effet c'est comme deux aspects de
facettes d'un miroir qu'on me décrit et
la plupart du temps quand je demande de
me décrire ya la deal qui est
indépendant l'adil qui osent parler qui
osent parler devant public
l'adil qui a l'air confiant mais pour la
plupart du temps je n'ai pas l'autre
facette qui est décrite l'adil qui est
vulnérable
l'adil qui doute l'adil qui apprend la
deal qui ne connaît pas tout l'adil qui
à moitié marocain moitié algérien est à
moitié français l'adil qui adore la
nature et le désert il ya c'est adil là
c'est à dire que la plupart ne
connaissent pas eh bien il m'a fallu
aussi également du temps pour connaître
cette à lille là et toute mon expérience
a commencé un âge un âge assez jeunes en
effet j'avais environ 7 en 7 ans et
c'était une journée après deux mois
d'été
c'était la fameuse rentrée scolaire je
suis sûr que chacun ici a déjà été
confronté à ce sentiment leur la rentrée
scolaire
bien souvent la rentrée scolaire elle
est synonyme de l'inconnu synonyme d'end
vie d'excitation mais également avec la
joie de la joie de voir nos nouveaux
camarades de classe n'est ce pas
nouveaux camarades de classe nouvelle
école
on associe le premier jour d'école à
cela bien comment vous dire que moi mon
premier jour d'école
je veux pas vous mentir c'était beaucoup
plus comme cela je veux que je suis pas
le seul et bien c'est là me montrent que
le fait d'avoir mon premier jour d'école
c'était un jour significatif pour moi
non pas parce que c'était le premier
jour de l'école mais que c'était à ce
moment même que ma naïveté à 7 ans on a
pris un coup
effectivement j'arrive mon nouveau sac à
dos en mon nouveau sac à dos mes
nouvelles chaussures tout fier dans
cette nouvelle classe le nouveau
j'entends en et chuchotements c'est qui
lui
t'as vu comment ils se parlent t'as vu
comment il s'agit je regarde pas je fais
comme si de rien n'était au final c'est
normal lorsqu'il nous on est nouveau on
est toujours confronté à l'inconnu puis
vient l'heure de la sonnerie à la
sonnerie
on sait tous que la sonnerie à 7 ans
synonyme de liberté
tout le monde court dans la cour de
gauche à droite les garçons et les
filles se mêlent et bien là c'était
assez marrant de voir cela car l'âge de
7 ans j'ai pu constater qu'il y avait
une différence assez importante
en effet les garçons ils allaient jouer
au foot
les garçons il montrait pas leur
sentiment
or les filles elles s'étaient tous
ensemble en train de discuter en train
de jouer en train de parler de ce
qu'elle avait fait le week-end et moi
j'étais là au milieu comme abandonnés
comme différent et je me rappellerai
toujours cette fille charlotte elle
s'appelait elle est venue vers moi et
elle m'a dit mais tu es vraiment
différent toi dans tout non tout ce que
tu fais déjà tu parle bizarrement en
plus c'est nouveau mais pourquoi tu vas
pas jouer au foot comme tout le monde
pourquoi tu reste pas avec les garçons
t'es pas une fille non
que pensez vous comment vous vous auriez
réagi à l'âge de 7 ans si vous aviez
entendu cela est bien normal blanc
inévitablement on s'est remis en
question et j'ai commencé à me remettre
en question
jour après jour et jour après jour tout
simplement je grandissais et en pensant
naïvement que les choses allaient
s'améliorer
j'ai constaté que les choses s'empirent
est qu'ils étaient critiquées ont marre
seul est continuellement j'aurais tout
entendu deux des profs qui me négligeait
qui me disait que je n'arriverais nulle
part de mes élèves
mes camarades de classe qui me qui me
définissais comme efféminé ou encore
attention tenez vous bien il y a même
une fille qui a été jusqu'à dire que
j'étais les une fille mais que
malheureusement ma mère ça ne lui avait
pas plu donc ce qu'elle a fait elle a
fait une opération pour que je devais
une version malheureusement cette
opération la science ça fonctionne pas
toujours
elle a foiré et donc comme et la foire
et voilà ça m'a créé moi certifiant non
j'ai même pu alors là ce a gelé toute
mon existence
ouais mais lui les quais c'est vrai il
est gay pensez-y les garçons qui aiment
la littérature des garçons qui
s'expriment les garçons qui ne sont pas
ce que la société nous montre comme
viril bah c'est gai c'est tout on se
pose pas de question et bien un jour je
me rappelle à l'âge de 7 ans à l'âge de
16 ans plus tôt je suis rentré à la
maison triste déprimé et j'ai parlé avec
ma mère à ma mère qui est présent ici
dans cette salle et à qui je dois
énormément de choses bien ma mère lui
dit tu en as assez
pourquoi les gens me jugent en
permanence pourquoi tout le temps
pourquoi on me critique
or moi j'ai rien demandé et c'est là
qu'elle m'a répondu écoute mon enfant
imagine toi comme dans un carrefour
tu as de route devant toi de choix tu as
deux fois que tu peux prendre le premier
le plus simple c'est de te conformer des
temps parmi les autres
c'est de tout simplement laisser ce que
les autres pensent te définir être toi
mais c'est pas ce choix là que tu vas
prendre
elle a dit tu va relever la tête elle
m'a dit tu vas prendre le deuxième choix
tu vas décidé de prendre sa vie en main
tu vas décidé d'aller loin tu vas décidé
d'être comme le bonhomme que vous voyez
là à l'écran le bonhomme en bleu qui n'a
pas peur d'aller à contre sens eh bien
c'est ce que j'ai fait à l'âge de 16 ans
je me suis rendu compte que j'avais le
choix que j'avais l'opinion de laisser
ce que les autres et la société voulait
que je sois me définir ou bien me
définir moi même et j'ai commencé j'ai
commencé à avoir mon journal j'ai
commencé à voir ce qui me plaisait me
plaisait pas et je me suis découvert
mois cette partie que j'avais oublié
cette partie qui était moi adil le vrai
et maintenant j'ai 19 ans 19 ans c'est
vrai je suis pas le meilleur en maths je
suis pas le meilleur en sport mais à
l'âge de 19 ans j'ai j'ai voulu
m'intéresser aux autres m'intéresser à
vous à chacun d'entre vous et j'ai fait
des recherches et j'ai vu que ma
situation
en effet ma situation elle ne touche pas
que moi ma situation
elle touche plus de jalons en soi
pourquoi eh bien les faits le montre
regardez plus de 75 % des filles est
également des garçons ont une estime de
soi qui est faible mais pourquoi posons
nous la question de savoir pourquoi
c'est vrai on en 2019 bombardé par
l'illusion que nous sommes illimitées
l'illusion que nous pouvons manifester
pour le climat que nous pouvons être qui
nous voulons nous pour faire les études
que nous voulons mais pensez-y vous les
jeunes ici présents pourquoi va-t-on à
l'école est-ce pour soi pour son futur
où est ce qu'on va à l'école pour plaire
à maman à papa pensez-y également
l'environnement de l'école y a pas pire
comme pression il faut avoir les
meilleures notes les meilleures notes
que notre voisin que le doigt sinn il
faut avoir une vie sociale c'est très
important
il faut avoir une vie digne d'être vus
par les autres il faut avoir les
meilleurs like les laïcs les réseaux
sociaux les jeunes sont confrontés par
des pressions incroyables au quotidien
pas étonnant
les chiffres le démontrent pas étonnant
que plus de 75% de la population et des
jeunes
vous les jeunes le futur n'en peuvent
plus car à force d'essayer de plaire à
gauche et à droite d'essayer de d'avoir
la satisfaction des autres on oublie
l'essentiel sa satisfaction en soi
eh bien pourquoi je vous dis cela
pourquoi j'ai décidé de n'accepter
d'accepter d'être ici aujourd'hui devant
vous bien si j'ai fait cela c'est pour
vous montrez vous que vous avez vous
avez le choix
vous en tant qu'étudiant mais également
en tant qu'adulte vous avez le choix de
créer vos propres limites et c'est vos
devoirs à vous même de créer vos limites
à vous car nous les êtres humains
pensez-y ne sommes pas sur cette terre
pour ne pas se poser de questions nous
sommes sur ses terres tout simplement
pour être libre libre dans le sens plein
du terme se découvrir alors essayez
juste un jour essayer un jour si vous
êtes timide
lever la main si vous n'osez pas vous
exprimer
bien exprimez vous et voyez qu'est ce
que ça fait juste un jour et vous allez
voir que petit à petit vous allez vous
découvrir et votre vie bavard en ce sens
un sens plein et vous allez vous
retrouver vous en tant qu'individu et
c'est ça l'essence même de la vie
je suis pas ici pour vous présenter
l'utopie je ne vous dis pas que ce sera
facile au contraire
au contraire ce choix demande beaucoup
de courage
énormément de courage vous allez être
jugé vous allez être parfois même
injustement critiqué vous allez être
confrontés mais pensez-y
quel est l'impact le plus lourd
vivre une vie certes qui a plu à notre
entourage mais où on s'est oubliée où on
est comme la peinture que je vous ai
montré au début comme gommer de notre
être
ou bien vivent une vie on a eu la
certitude peut-être qu'on a eu des
personnes qui nous ont abandonnés mais
on en a eu la certitude d'avoir été nous
et on se rendra compte qu'à la fin de
notre existence
on s'est trouvés c'est le plus beau
cadeau que vous puissiez vous faire
avoue même pas à moi alors essayez fait
le car au final nous sommes tous ici
présents tous tous les mêmes nous sommes
tous des papillons touzet papillon qui
qui rêvent de voler mais pour voler faut
s'en donner la peine et vous êtes le
maître
vous êtes les maîtres de votre existence
alors prenez ce pouvoir entre vos mains
et faites de votre vie la traduction de
qui vous êtes fait le nom pour moi et
créer une vie illimitée
une vie qui a du sens pour vous et pour
chacun d'entre vous présent ici il ya
également une métaphore assez plaisante
qui qui englobe bien ce que j'ai envie
de vous montrer la plupart dans la
société actuelle c'est comme si on avait
un téléphone qui retentissait jour après
jour la sonnerie sonne c'est vrai il
sole mais on ne décroche pas on ignore
un jour passe le deuxième passe
et bien moi je vous dis je vous dis tout
simplement de décrocher le téléphone
écoutez cette voix cette voix en vous
juste un jour histoire de voir ce que ça
donne juste un jour pour vous et
là que vous vous rendrez compte que
votre vie elle est illimitée et vous
créez vos propres limites à vous il ya
une citation de nietzsche qui résume
bien qui résume bien mes propos qui est
tout simplement de dire dozois dancing
with him insein
pie xii auquel ni penser à cette phrase
ce ceux qui dansaient il était vu comme
fou comme incompréhensible par ceux qui
au final
n'écoutez pas bien malheureusement la
plupart d'entre nous n'écoute pas et jus
bien soyez parmi ceux qui dansent ceux
qui n'ont pas peur de lever leur main
ceux qui n'ont pas peur de s'exprimer
que ce soit avec vos choix
vestimentaires mais vos choix au
quotidien soyez fous et c'est là que
vous serez illimitée merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]